jo leute herzlich willkommen zum
heutigen kontakt ich hatte heute keine
lust mich einfach bei diesem 25 grad die
es bei uns hier waren voll computer zu
setzen und irgendein video aufzunehmen
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich gehe
einfach in der natur und kann das ganze
auch einfach mal film wir haben dann
einfach ein paar oster ähnliche
schokoladen teile mitgenommen und haben
die dann irgendwo im vorgarten gestellt
auf autos gelegt et cetera
dass das dann vielleicht ein paar kinder
ein paar leute einfach finden und
andenken hoch wie kommt das denn hier
hin
aber egal ich würde einfach sagen musik
ab und viel spaß beim video statt
du bist gefragt warum ich denn kein lied
schreibt da hab ich mir gedacht ein
guten kriegs als du hast gesagt ich soll
nicht ehrlich beschreiben du bist alles
wird denn so schwer das zu zeigen
unsere beine häufig streiten zumindest
nicht wenn einer von unten stehst du
fragst wichtig finde auch wenn ich nicht
weiß wozu ich dachte solche dinge die
entscheidest du natürlich können meine
kumpels treiben die kommt nicht mehr zum
zweiten weil wir sonst so schlecht mit
dem bus zu erreichen
doch mal nur sieben reicht ich frag mich
häufig rolle da wie so ein glück
verdient das ist
aber nach dem bürgerkrieg ich das alter
besser leben zu sein
du bist nicht dein gene sind gemeint
schlag mich nicht egal worum geht es
richtig
ich sag dir das
arschloch ich hoffe dass du mit deiner
doch die weiße fliege und ardian ich
hasse weißen und natürlich wird nach
apples katzenbabys ich hab gedacht ich
sag dir lass mich jeden tag stürzt ich
glaube trotzdem spaß finde ich auch löst
immer einfach so dass ich meine musik
bleibt vorausgesetzt dass ich nur lena
albrecht reiz ja ich finde beide passen
gut zusammen
ich hab an und besitzen grad und da hab
ich denke dass du einfach süchtig bist
aber schon nein natürlich nicht
doch ja ich weiß
für die stimme meiner mailbox natürlich
darf ich mich mit meinen freunden
treffen gehen wenn sie schließlich
warum ich das alles hier nochmals die
gleiche angst und es geht weiter wie
gewohnt
denn ich habe nichts zu verlieren
ich sag dir haben
ich hoffe du mit deiner auf diverse
fließen
die chance weiß natürlich wird man um
sich anzumelden
nun will ich hab gesagt leute das war's
auch schüler mit dem heutigen kontakt
wenn es euch gefallen und die eventuell
mehr von solchen anderen tagen haben
wollte ihr den jetzt gerade gesehen habt
lasst einfach den daumen hoch dann sehe
ich dass ihr einfach mal das haben wird
oder sich und schreibt mir doch mal die
kommentare was ihr heute so alles
gemacht hat bei den super wetter schaut
euch noch einen schönen tag